hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt ich mich heute ein schnelles
party rezept machen ein rezept für gäste
ich war heute eine quiche eine
vegetarische und zwar besteht die
außerdem wirbt dann kommt da so eine
füllung rein so ein bus aus markise
masse du darfst nur auch helfen und die
mache ich heute mit tomaten also kiez
vielleicht können viele quiche lorraine
mit speck und mit lauch und so weiter
und ich mache heute vegetarische
variante mit einem starken käse und
milch schmeckt es ziemlich gut weil man
kann das warm und kalt es also mal ganz
gut vorbereitet und zum beispiel dann
mittags einfach mal zum snack essen und
ich zeige euch mal kurze zutaten als für
den mürbeteig brauchen wir 250 gramm
mehl
ich habe 125 gramm kalte butter 1
teelöffel salz und ein ei und für die
füllung brauche ich drei ein
ich habe zwei esslöffel mehl 150 gramm
käse da habe ich jetzt ein appenzeller
so ein mittel reifen sagen ich las dazu
250 gramm quark und 400 milliliter sahne
nächsten vier milliliter milch und dann
brauche ich einfach ein paar gewürze und
ein paar tomaten
also ich mache das ganze jetzt in der
küchenmaschine ihr könnt es aber
natürlich auch wie immer ohne machen als
alle meine rezepte funktionieren
normalerweise immer auch ohne
küchenmaschine zuerst mal jetzt den weg
nach oben drin gebe ich mail und die
butter rein dann auch gleich das salz
und das wird jetzt kurz vor mixed
und wenn ihr jetzt merkt da ist zu
krümmel ich geb dir einfach ein schluck
kaltes wasser rein
genau aber ich hatte eine maske
jetzt habe ich hier die teig kugel und
ich habe da kein wasser gebraucht und so
meine fast perfekt gewesen
ja aber ich habe es genau so und jetzt
gebe ich hier ein bisschen mehr drauf
und ich wollte mit schönen rund aus und
zwar bei den heute in so einer tat form
als ich habe wie er seine tat frau mit
einem hebel boden habe ich jetzt eine
ganz neue form und zwar hat die löcher
das sorgt dafür dass meine tat einfach
etwas knuspriger wert also das eben
später wenn sie backt eben am rand da
geht dann die feuchtigkeit rauskommt
oder wird der teig zum glück und
knusprig und zum hebel boden würde ich
euch sowieso immer empfehlen weil man
später wenn die tat fertig ist fertig
einfach das so rausnehmen kann
du hast hier mal mäuschen unterwegs
heute wird es fertig aus
und den teig habe ich jetzt etwas größer
als die form ausgerollt als sieht man
jetzt hier und ich das ganz gut sich
folge am besten hier kurz darauf mit das
silikon matte und wetten durch die
backform jetzt mit meinem back trends
für das geht einfach total schnell und
ich brauche keinen pinsel oder so dafür
und belegt jetzt den teig darüber was
macht jetzt auch nichts wenn der heißt
oder so den machen als jetzt
zudem legen
und die backform die lege ich jetzt auf
meine back folie denn es könnte jetzt
auch passieren dass damals 100 tropf
durch die löcher oder so und da gehe ich
es einfach auf nummer sicher legt es auf
meinem bacchus und so muss der teig
jetzt erst mal vor gebacken werden dann
ist nämlich der teig fast schon durch
und dann gehen wir gleich die käsemasse
ein also ich gibt es jetzt in der oper
und in der zeit bereiten wir gleich
schon mal die käsemasse vor das ganze
pack ich jetzt bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für ungefähr 15 minuten vor
jetzt kann ich die käsemasse zu bereiten
dafür gebe ich den käse jetzt da oben
reinigenden mixa als jetzt kein mixa
benutzten müsse den käse einfach fein
reiben
ich habe jetzt wie gesagt ein
appenzeller das ist ein relativ starker
würziger käse
ich habe jetzt die mittlere reife
genommen also denkt gibt es ein mittel
alt und jung und wichtig ist einfach
egal welchen käse nimmt hauptsache er
hat mindestens 45 prozent fettanteil
weil dann schmilzt nämlich im backofen
und dann wird es eben so eine schöne
krise kriegen
im prinzip können wir jetzt wirklich
jeden anderen kees aufnehmen also am
besten wenn ihr vielleicht so eine
käsetheke im supermarkt habt geht eher
dahin lasst euch beraten
könnt ihr auch probieren wenn euch das
zu stark wer können auch in anderen
nehme einfach mal ausprobieren so habe
ich das auch gemacht
und dann kommen jetzt einfach die
restlichen zutaten noch mit rein bei mir
schoss übrigens so bisserl die light
variante also normalerweise gehört in so
einer quiche oder inseln zum beispiel
ganz viel sahne
ich hab die sahne als dreiviertel liter
sahne gewesen
ich habe die sache jetzt ersetzt durch
quark und milch finde ich schmeckt
nämlich auch sehr lecker und wird
trotzdem schön cremig allein schon durch
den käse dann kommt jetzt noch milch
rein also könnte einfach selber
bestimmen wie ihr das mache wollte
wirklich jetzt einfach alle zutaten
reihen
ich würde es jetzt mit bisschen salz
nicht zu viel das weiß vielleicht ein
halber teelöffel etwas pfeffer
etwas chili muss nicht aber ich finde
das macht also geschmack auch aus dann
etwas thymian oder nehmt ihr einfach so
viel ihr wollt hoops das weizen tick zu
viel
naja macht nichts
käsecreme ist fertig und ich warte jetzt
noch etwa sechs minuten auf meinem mac
boden und dann geht's gleich weiter
mein tag ist jetzt vorgebacken und jetzt
kann ich die tomaten nehmen und die
schneide ich jetzt auch gar nicht klein
sondern legt er einfach drauf übrigens
falls sie jetzt festgestellt habe der
teig normalerweise sticht neue website
immer ein und bat den blind das musste
ich jetzt hier gar nicht machen
allein dadurch dass diese form einfach
diese löcher hat und das geht hier in
der form echt nett hoch also dann bleibt
er muschelfleisch und die tomaten die
lege ich jetzt hier rings vom rhein
übrigens falls ihr euch wundert was sie
neben mir die ganzen dampf karten der
suppe also bei uns gibt's halt nicht nur
eine kitsch sondern auch eine super und
das sieht man hier die ganze zeit im
bild nur dass ihr euch nicht wundert was
base und blubbert schaut unser essen
third mittag
richtig hübsch sieht die kirche übrigens
aus wenn man bunte tomaten hat also
sondern richtig schöne tomate mix den
gab's jetzt leider mit deswegen gibt es
bei uns eine rote sondern nehme ich den
basilikum moment einen volt für die deko
und den schneide ich jetzt mit einer
schere einfach in so schwer in so
streifen
und das gebe ich jetzt über die tomaten
trüber
dann kommt jetzt die käsecreme
jetzt kommt das ganze wieder in den
backofen ich mache dann schon mal auf
was kann ich nicht tragen
und da packe ich die kirche jetzt noch
mal für etwa 35 minuten fertig
meine kiss ist jetzt aus dem ofen raus
ich habe sie jetzt auch knapp 20 minuten
abkühlen lassen weil ganz heiß will ich
mir auch nicht den mund verbrennen
und jetzt kann ich hier ganz einfach den
rand lösen natürlich vorsichtig mich vor
ein bisserl käsermeister runtergelaufen
deswegen klebte setzte bisserl da war
ein bisschen schusselig österliche
krümelt hier ja ich mache es gleich
wieder sauber okay und jetzt sehe ich
die tische mit dem teig retter runter
wird geschimpft man schnell die krümel
weg kontrolliert alles mit ihrer lupe
und ich schneide
willst du dir auch probieren mäuschen
ich habe alles sehr ehrliches kind so
sieht jetzt von innen aus also unten der
mürbeteig dann die käse schicht mit den
leckeren tomaten und es darf jetzt die
karima probieren denn heute immer wieder
mit dabei so ich bin sehr gespannt
sie sieht nicht nur gut aus sondern im
irak ist stinkt hier drin
diese schalter käse ich finde es sowieso
faszinierend also eigentlich als kind
marketing kuchen und später gewöhnt was
ich tragen keine ahnung oder ändert sich
der geschmack auf jeden fall macht dann
plötzlich und sehr gut
aber weißt du was ist für mich noch viel
chili ganz genau fehlt mir jetzt noch
tiere ganz war ich hole jetzt gleich mal
portion chili und riecht es hier noch
schön an damit karima noch ganz scharf
das essen kann
tabasco wasser wobei der sowjet den
eigenen geschmack habe ich mal wieder zu
passen
ich habe jetzt mein flächen tag an sport
und dann kam mir an wo gibt's das rezept
auf
genau da gibt's das rezept zum nachlesen
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
bringt nachbacken schmeckt zwar rot card
richtig gut gegangen